this one is just have you ever smoked a
cig in a hot tub
[Laughter]
[Applause]
for some reason
it doesn't work man you're sweating it's
too hot that's all right
relaxing all right we gotta get moving
here this is
oh where's gen B at Jenny where are you
at you here hun
gry what's your name
just
married now would your email be gen B
what yeah
what the [ __ ] is going on
in Kansas slash Missouri
slash the 1800s right now
that might be me you look like he got
married in between the show
well I don't go by that name anymore
but for the first 22 years of my life I
was gnb
[Music]
so yeah okay that is you yeah
well played Jen B well played
I like the husband yeah that's her don't
worry she's all right she's cool she's
cool just don't touch your ears you'll
be all right I promise you
[ __ ] awesome
this is the lackiest one we've ever
[Applause]
I've got to do that same [ __ ] answer for
like that's fine
that's great
all right and where are you from Jen
okay nice are you here with your husband
how long have you guys are married
three and a half years very nice where'd
you guys get married Vegas all right
here we go there we go finally some
class in here
hahaha
couldn't get jacked up at some bake sale
in the face I had a [ __ ] eating lemon
squares you still were getting turned
the [ __ ] up
was it somewhat traditional in Vegas
say no more brother say no more
it's all right
all right Jen
is it garbage to use okay
is it garbage to use Grandpa's cut up
tighty whities to dust the house
[Applause]
now that's Missouri [ __ ] right there
[Applause]
he didn't cut them off of them did you
quit squirming God damn it the coffee
table's a mess
thank you
I mean
man why what
how about your paper towels out here
there's Grandpa
can I get a cup of coffee up here please
and a monster for the guy in the second
row
is this something your family did
okay when did they do this
your grandmother did this so this is
that your grandfather in your
grandmother's house and your
grandfather's underwear got a little
frayed or whatever or he [ __ ] his pants
foreign
[Music]
and your grandmother would cut them up
and use them for different things around
the house
hi what were you saying
a bit
bit come on now now you're trying to say
face yeah they were pre-owned yeah they
started they weren't certified though
yeah
it was a couple miles on them yeah they
were bonded a lot not a dealership if
they were a car
man Patty would do it with like t-shirts
and stuff with an underwear white like
tidy whities right yeah yeah to him
wait yellow lines from what
from doo doo what do you think idiot
no for what I'm sorry
I was Pee
yeah what brand has yellow
that guy just woke up by the way
where the [ __ ] did you come from
he was sleeping the whole time
in research and development over in
Haynes
actually the 1970s they started a
cross-stitching program where they used
so yellow thread up the back and through
the testicular area
let's go right back to sleep
it's kind of trashy what no that's very
trashy
well thank you
as long as it wasn't the dishes
ah you're coming home with us I'll tell
you that right now you say goodbye to
whoever you got
to do with me dude I wouldn't want you
cleaning my toilet with old underwear
all right one more time for Jim yeah
that looks beautiful beautiful